-♪ Ramen Challenge,
Ramen Challenge ♪
♪ R-A-M-E-N Challenge ♪
♪♪
-All right, now,
here's how this works.
-You have to go first
'cause I don't know --
It looks really complicated.
-No, no, no.
It's not.
You can totally nail this.
This is easy.
Our pal Chef David Chang
and this place called Sun Noodle
made us these special
four foot long ramen noodles.
There are six of them in this
bowl, three for each of us.
And we have three shots of sake.
You slurp up your whole noodle,
then you take a shot --
-Where do you start --
on this part...
-Yeah.
-...or the end?
-No, not the end.
You start with that part.
-You take it out of the stick.
That's not some crazy thing.
-No, there's not a trick.
This is easy to do.
Just slurping noodles
like "Lady and the Tramp."
You saw "Lady and the Tramp?"
-You start sucking yourself.
-No.
-"Sucking" --
What?
-Then I see how you suck,
and then I try.
-[ Chuckling ]
What's going on?
No, slurping.
Slurping.
-Ah.
-I'll start slurping, myself,
and --
-There's a difference between
sucking and slurping!
-Yes, yes, yes, yes.
[ Laughter ]
-Whatever.
-We'll do it
on the commercial break.
Uh, we will --
You slurp the noodle,
and then you take a shot.
Whoever finishes
all three first wins.
-Oh, we have to do it
at the same time.
-Yeah, and --
Let's get our first noodle
in position.
-But, Jimmy, you take it
out of here, no?
-It's just a noodle.
Your teeth can probably bite
through it if you want to,
but -- All right.
And it's also customary --
-I just don't understand
the stick part!
[ Laughter ]
How do you suck
with the stick in the middle?
-[ Laughs ]
-I don't like things to get
in my way when I'm sucking.
-You'll learn, you'll learn.
You'll figure it out.
Gosh!
[ Laughs ]
-This is cheating.
I can imagine you in your house,
you know, practicing.
-Wait! No, no, no!
Don't -- I'm not practicing.
-For hours. Okay.
-Hours?!
Trust me.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cymbal crashes ]
-Let's do this.
Let's get the sucking
out of the way.
[ Band plays funky music ]
[ Laughter continues ]
-Also, it's customary
to lock eyes with your opponent
the whole time.
[ Chuckles ]
Ready?
3, 2, 1, slurp.
[ Band plays bossa nova music ]
[ Scattered cheers ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Mm!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Music tempo quickens ]
[ Bell dinging ]
Wait! No, I'm not --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Salma!
-Oh, my God.
-They're giving it to you.
Dude, you beat me at my --
[ Laughs ]
-[ Speaking Spanish ]
♪ Da da da da-da, da da ♪
-Nice.
They're giving it to you.
You did it.
[ Laughing ] Oh, my God.
-I'm drunk!
-That was fun.
It tasted good, too.
All right. I lost.
I lost,
so I'm gonna take the loss.
What does the losing card say?
-Okay, he lost.
-My losing prize --
I get to lead an invisible
marching band out of the studio,
into the elevators,
and out of the building.
Roots, can we get some
marching band music, please?
-But you have to go
with a salsa march.
[ Marching band music plays ]
-This should have been you.
[ Chuckles ]
♪♪
Salma Hayek, everybody!
More "Tonight Show"
after the break!
Stick around!
[ Audience clapping
rhythmically ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]